we just arrived what the current is and
the voltage these are both the natural
response of the RC now what I did is I
went ahead and I plotted out that's
using a computer just using Excel to
plot out what these two expressions look
like and let me show you that
so let's do a real quick example here
with real values just to see how this
equation works we'll say that this is
1000 ohms
that's our resistor and we'll say C is 1
micro farad and what we want to work out
is R times C equals 10 to the third
times 10 to the minus sixth and that
equals 10 to the minus 3 seconds or 1
millisecond that's the product of R and
C I forgot V nought let's say let's say
we put 2 volts on this capacitor to
start with like that and now we can say
V of T equals V naught 2 volts times e
to the minus T over 1 millisecond and
that's our natural response for this
particular circuit now let me show you
what that looks like this is V of T on
this side equals to e to the minus T
over 1 millisecond and you can see it
starts at 2 volts and then sags down as
we predicted and that's an exponential
curve and then over here on this side I
as we send before starts out at zero in
the capacitor the current and the
capacitor is zero and as soon as we
throw open that switch the charge
charges over through the resistor and
this is the equation here I of T equals
two volts over 1,000 e to the minus T
over RC or
tea over one millisecond so this is what
we call the natural response of an RC
circuit and you'll run into this in
almost every circuit you ever build